welcome back to me rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Captain Marvel gave the
Avengers their namesake Nick Fury as
eyepatch ants pardon me far from home
it's bunkers post-credit scene when this
movie came out I think we're all just
itch and I get to Avengers end game but
this Carol Danvers free haircut days
turned up a lot of interesting visual
details and connections souther MCU
films that I missed the first time
around let's rewrite this down the
Marvel Studios title card is a loving
tribute to Stan Lee this being the first
MCU film to release after his death his
many forms and his many creations make
him the true Avenger that made this
cinematic universe possible Stan cameos
later on the train freshman beaver trust
me he's reading the script for Kevin
Smith's Mallrats
since this is set 1995 when Stan made
one of his best cameos all the money all
the women even all the comic books in
the world
they can't substitute for that one
person I don't know the comics in the
world
trust me true believer one girl who got
away it's Carol Danvers here on a deeper
level it's also the core drive for
Avengers like Captain America and
endgame
when Kevin Smith saw Stan reading this
line in Captain Marvel he immediately
remembered the mole rat seeds deeper
meaning and was brought to tears the
film opens with Carol's fractured memory
of her crash origin doctor to render her
blood blue and the hazy threat a dirty
scroll but already we feel like there's
something off about this it's because
Carol's story is really about memory
they say that when we remember something
we're actually remembering how we felt
the last time we thought about that
event an echo of an echo memory is
subjective our minds are constantly
reframing our pasts however they'll
strengthen us for our present battles
Carol's memory has been falsified to
make her a stronger Kree so she must
reclaim her narrative to make herself a
better human the planet ala is
introduced with these coordinates using
the production design from the guardians
of the galaxy movies along with the
hexagonal Universal neural teleportation
Network and Peter Quill's translator
implant which Carol also has the
understanding is when
that are working they designed the
crease skyscrapers with a t-shape and
down below there's a structure with 10
pillars there are also 10 pillars on the
sanctum of the supreme intelligence I
assume it represents the 10 pillars of
why decree or pricks now I have other
matters to attend to and the T shape
stands for it's time for Carol to leave
the train level of hala features some
anti Skrull propaganda another hint of
the Orwellian undertones or overtones of
the Kree society never a good sign when
there are freakin billboards that say
watch out for this race the Big Brother
of this society is the AI supreme
intelligence has anyone ever seen what
the supreme intelligence really looks
like and one can look upon the supreme
intelligence in its true form
yeah sounds very great and Powerful oz
to me this is an emerald city of Wow
like the false perception green tinted
glasses of Oz they use green eyes to
mark the false projection of the trusted
figure Marvel aka windy Lawson but
carol's actual memories reveal the real
Marvel did not have this eye color Yan
raagh tells his team
we must we'll be ready to join the
collective if that is our fate today
later Talos eulogizes his dead scroll
friend differently
when the Kree die they assimilate into a
collective their souls conforming in
solidarity but when the Skrull die they
drift outward into the beyond it's a
nice contrast between the conforming
fascist Kree versus the roaming refugee
scrolls the scars can Carol's memories
with maria rambo callsign photon a nod
to her daughter Monica Rambeau
adult virgin join the MCU in Wan
Division who becomes the hero photon aka
pulsar and most importantly another
version of Captain Marvel the [ __ ]
pilot bullies earner memory is briefly
shown in the background of the Kree
sparring room exactly where Carol looked
up at yon rug a clue to her here that
young rock is actually another
oppressive authority figure that she
shouldn't trust now there's this brief
shot of a burning piano the story behind
this is pilots will burn pianos as a way
to honor pilots that they've lost a
tradition that dates back at least to
World War two maybe earlier according to
some legends RAF pilots burned a piano
to honor a piano playing pilot who would
no more in this case it's a kind of meta
tribute to Thunderbird pilot major
Steven cajón del bag know who died in a
crash shortly after consulting on this
film he and fellow consultant major Matt
Kimmel cameo at the whole table in the
Poncho's barred memory and the credits
make the whole film out - del bag knows
memory another memory Carroll's star
gazes with Monica and there's a shooting
star which I have speculated might have
been yondu's ship taking off since this
would be around 1988 and Louisiana isn't
that far from Missouri where quill was
abducted Carol dick names Monica prepare
for takeoff trouble in the comics Carol
gives the nickname lieutenant trouble to
KITT Renner a Captain Marvel fan who
helps to recover from amnesia as Monica
doesn't miss movie her memory of windy
Lawson loops back on itself with Lawson
leaving frame in the same shot that
Carol with my hands over to see Lawson
walking back in Doctor Strange used a
similar disorienting camera trick when
strange tortured Dormammu with the same
kind of time loop so they keep the
camera rolling within this impossible
loop to convey that bewilderment from
that perspective in a blockbuster Carol
says beers to star force command do you
read me
it's a nod to Buzz Lightyear in Toy
Story which also came out in 95 when a
similarly confused crash-landed Space
Ranger makes a similar distress call
Buzz Lightyear to Star Command come in
Star Command Carol picks up the movie
the right stuff but is the famous film
about test pilots as she and Maria work
Jeep blasts the stand II for true lies
burning off the head of Arnold's
character who is a spy who deceived his
wife who then becomes the badass
parallel to how jaan raghav Carol but
then she ends up being the badass the
security guard Barry is actually a cameo
by Barry Curtis Marvel's longtime
security guy who works his ass off to
try to prevent spoiler leaks by the cast
is Barry gonna be mad look how mad Barry
is now four Scrolls arrive on the beach
Talos is their leader squirrel number
two impersonates Coulson and he dies in
the car crash later gets autopsy
squirrel number three it's Talos says
science guy who gets killed by yon rug
now scroll number four is the one Carol
chases on the train and gets away my old
scroll search series on the channel went
into some possibilities of whatever
happened to this fourth scroll of some
more thoughts on it at the end of this
video
the posters by the payphone include ones
for the 90s
Rock the Vote campaign and Smashing
Pumpkins Mellon Collie and the infinite
sadness which might be a nod to brie
Larson as in the Adams and Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world which was adapted from the
comics in which her character debuted in
an issue titled the infinite sadness she
tells John rod which sees on c53 B is
where are you girls are looking for
someone in Wasson he is briefly out to
be if she is back on her home planet and
she's about to find out how he lied to
her shield agents young Nick Fury and
young Coulson try to handle this
situation you see her weapon not not
very good at faking surprise that this
alien weaponry because Coulson here
sexually scroll stood the scroll helps
the old lady that he impersonates off
the train Carol runs into her as well
showing how she recognizes this scroll
as an imposter her glasses fly off but
she doesn't need them as Talos explains
later you know
I don't really need these to see but
they do kind of complete the look now
when they hold her back there's a
passenger in a suit he looks different
between takes that's because the earlier
shot is an extra but in the clothes of
the guy who ends up getting hit is this
movies fight coordinator Walter Garcia
who had to dress up as the original
extra win they went back to reshoot the
scene scroll changes into the guy in the
red sweater who reacts confused doing a
real solid job conveying how Korath
described this feeling it was deeply
disturbing
why because I stared into the face of my
moto enemy and a face stand back was my
own enemies before I continued thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories yet
it tastes great
I definitely winced when I opened it
yeah there's over 20 different flavors
to choose from this one is their black
cherry vanilla it's like all my favorite
flavors in one can that gives me so much
energy whenever I'm feeling sluggish I
can't one of these guys helps pick me up
so I never have to blink again okay I
just did I gotta judge some more never
blink
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at bang - energy calm
and use the code new rock stars 25 there
you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kind of stuff to
be your best bang so thanks again to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25% off at bang - energy comm using
the code in new rock stars 25 and when
Carol gets off the train there's a quick
cameo by Captain Marvel Comics writer
Kelly sue Taconic at the computer bar
Carol researches Pegasus in these search
results bring up the mythological
Pegasus setting up Valkyries steed in
in-game there's also listening for the
Disney film Hercules but hey that didn't
come out until 1997 come on the scroll
autopsy was inspired by a memorable
moment in the Secret Invasion comics and
the medical examiner here is actor
Nelson Franklin who also appeared on
agents of shield as agent Steve Wilson
at the atcu an entity that deals with
Inhumans at Pancho's bar the Street
Fighter 2 game shows him bison doing his
psycho crusher move which you think
about it is similar to the way Captain
Marvel goes binary and supercharged it's
a roll body through a ship to blow it up
suggesting she might have gotten the
idea for that move from play in this
game the walls are covered in plain
photos including one that people thought
was the Valkyrie from the first Captain
America movie but it's actually the YB
49 which is built after World War 2 come
on folks it's an Air Force bar they're
gonna hang up a hydroplane on the wall
unless they been corrupted to hell
Nick Fury fills our in on his past as a
spy where was the Cold War we were
everywhere belfast bucharest belgrade
budapest i like to be a second megaman
Budapest is gonna be a setting in the
upcoming Black Widow film maybe we might
see it Nick Fury cameo or at least his
old safehouse Bucharest was where Bucky
was hiding in Civil War always that fury
could've been helping him out with his
old contacts the MCU has filled Fury's
past with these be locations as we found
out in Winter Soldier that photo was
taken five years after Nick and I met
when I was at State Department in
Bordeaux and Athena Winter Soldier you
can see he has a tie work permit
suggesting maybe work
Bangkok very also reveals his infamous
toast cutting pet peeve naima details so
bizarre a scroll could never fabricate
it toasters cut diagonally I can't eat
it and again I got us at the record
straight about age of Ultron where many
of you keep tweeting me play me that you
can see fury cutting coasts diagonally
calling the scroll evidence but no trust
me I've watched that scene so many times
gone through it frame by frame
I deserve a doctorate degree in this
fury definitely cuts that bread and it's
not toast it's bread he cuts it at a
90-degree angle
there are four sides four corners it is
not diagonal here he also makes a big
point about his name nicholas joseph
fury you have three names everybody
calls me fury not nicholas not joseph
not Nick just fury which is how he knows
that his boss is actually Talos
excellent work Nicholas more on how this
could explain what really happened to
scroll number four at the end of the
video series ID list his birthday as
July 4th just like Steve Rogers and
currently he is shield level 3 since
this is early in his career later he
will rise to clearance level 10 Fury
uses the old get the thumbprint on tape
and put down the door scanner
trick that Scott Lang use to infiltrate
Hank Pym mansion fury also says or you
should see what I could do it
paperclip now he probably doesn't mean
it this way but Operation Paperclip was
how Arnim Zola ended up working for and
infiltrating shield a really shield use
paperclip to undermine itself goose the
cat or we should say Gustav lurkin was
named a Chewie in the comics the name
goose is a nod to Mavericks co-pilot and
Top Gun and when they find the
classified records you could start to
see the big reveal from the end of the
movie Carol's callsign Avenger it's
obscured here though and they end up
escaping in a quad jet this is a
predecessor to the Quinn jet that the
Avengers would later use actually the
coordinates on the controls are these
same coordinates as the quinjets heading
when they take cap to the Helicarrier
and Avengers I'm just guessing they
reused a set piece I just lent me in the
wasp they don't really design these
cockpits that well via Cal our pal
ronan appears Ronan the accuser from
guardians of galaxy is not yet
that crazy later on he will be joined by
koreff who shows up in this movie at the
end of the film he says will be
for the weapon the core a woman
suggesting that there will be more to
this backstory between the films and
that perhaps we'll get explored in
Captain Marvel - coming July 20 22 at
the rambo farm they join up with Talos
who sips the same kind of pet food Cup
as a Big Kahuna burger Cup that Sam
Jackson drinks out of in Pulp Fiction
tailless recognizes goose as a flare
cannon he freaks out the way rocket does
he calls out the Fleur kid in the comics
but goose rubs against his legs leaving
the scent which is how goose recognizes
Talos through his credits Kai's later on
after learning the truth Karel changes
her creased suit color scheme she says
nope - red and gold either a joke about
this being the color scheme of Shazam
the character Marvel Comics took the
name Captain Marvel from originally or
give me a meta joke about how red and
gold has already kind of been taken the
MCU by Iron Man but she also tries out
this green and white scheme which is the
original Creek colors of Marvel in the
comics Jana rod tells the science guy
scroll that Carroll's Kree blood
transfusion came from him meaning he was
behind her memory wipe now this is the
same process Nick Fury will use to
revive Coulson and agents of shield
after his death and Avengers Kree blood
memory wipe maybe Fury learned this is
possible from what happened to Carol
Danvers the squirrel Lightspeed engines
energy core was of course the tesseract
meaning that after Howard Stark
recovered it from the ocean floor in the
40s he must have handed it off to shield
project Pegasus in the 80s and then it
stayed with the scrolls in the 90s and
then with Goose and with fury until the
Avengers they get captured and Carroll
gets trapped with the supreme
intelligence and she revisits all of her
memories of her past failures including
one where she plays baseball for the
team named sparrows which was the
call-sign brie Larson was given when
training with the air force pilots but
in this moment Carol reframes the echoes
of echoes into aligned moments when she
rose back super feat
she reclaims her memory as a weapon to
strengthen herself she removes her Curie
inhibitor chip in she goes binary she
tells fury take the tesseract
leap the lunchbox it's a nod to be
famous Godfather line leaves a good
take the cannoli who swallows the
tesseracts calm acting Bruce manners
line and Avengers this is the tesseract
it has the potential energy to wipe out
the planet
what does fury want me to do swallow it
they use the empty fawns lunch box as a
misdirect just like how the guardians of
the galaxy used a container to misdirect
yondu from that Infinity stones real
location now there's a great moment here
Carol looks down at the pawns lunchbox
and no doubts I'm just a girl kicks in
right as she blasts bran char into the
jukebox echoing when she blasted the
jukebox in the bar earlier is all a nod
to the way the Fonz and happy days could
punch the jukebox and play whatever song
he wanted she has Fonz power now now in
addition to the big reveal of Gustav
lurkin being a nod to the wait minute
black hides a whole galaxy on the cat's
collar in that movie being a whole alien
conspiracy story this final battle echos
another mid-90s sci-fi film Independence
Day there's a dogfight through the
canyon and Carol ends up dragging your
own rug through the desert to welcome
into earth like Will Smith to that alien
and now here she stands over him with a
light casting Hindman shadow a reversal
of the way that he stood over her in
latern shadow back on Halle and the
music here may sound familiar to you
[Music]
this music is light motif - Captain
America's theme the music of his longing
for Peggy you'll notice the fourth note
of Carol's theme diverges from what you
would expect reflecting how this avenger
diverges from that First Avenger Steve
Rogers was always trying to get back to
the woman of his past this Avenger wants
to move on from the man of hers goose
scratches Nick Fury's eye scarring his
eye with the permanent unique damage
that he uses to save shield from hydras
clutches and where soldier you need to
keep both we're didn't really save
shield I guess not but anybody saved us
Talos tells fury I could go back to
being your boss that these two will
continue to work together in a tandem
partnership which was revealed in
spider-man far from home Talos his wife
Sauron hear disguises herself as Maria
hill and again there was that long-lost
missing scroll number four I believe
that he could have continued on earth as
a close confidant of Fury and of he'll
maybe doubling up as either one of them
whenever they need him - that might
explain why fury throughout this
cinematic universe has allowed himself
to be called the Nick in various
instances those hostages could have died
Carroll upgrades Fury's pager for
emergencies only
okay explaining the backstory of furious
pager in the infinity war post-credits
team which returns and this movie's
post-credits scene where Carole joins
the Avengers
where's fury this moment was brie
Larson's first time on any Marvel set
and she said that when she shot this she
was just alone with green screens and
tape and she was never told which actors
she would begin the scene with which is
why she looks a little confused here
makes sense
the final scene reveals that Nick Fury's
Avengers initiative that he pitch to
Tony Stark was inspired by Carol Danvers
pilot callsign Fury learned from Carol
how for heroes memory can be a very
powerful tool the way the Kree reframed
Carol's memories to turn her against the
scroll enemy fury does reframe the
Avengers memories about Coulson which is
a bit deceitful because yeah memory is
subjective it's an echo of an echo that
our minds repackage as a motive to keep
us fighting on
long as those memories are weaponized to
fight the good fight that's what's
important and that call of the Avengers
began right here ventures endgame is our
next breakdown on this channel and as
our discord MC Yuri watch comes to an
end we are actually gonna move forward
with new films voted on by you guys to
these Sam Raimi spider-man so you can
join us on discord if you haven't
already by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on instagram at EA vas following new
rockstars and subscribe yeah I can ask
you to subscribe all day yeah I know
[Music]